[Music]
well thank you so much for being here
I'm going to start off by saying
apologize my voice a little bit it's a
little horar today but you guys are
going to hang in there with me today
we're going to talk about a really
important topic which is um
slideshow mode awesome we're going to
talk about a really important topic
which is about evaluating AI agents and
assistance this will load just to set a
little context before we we jump
in a lot of you have probably heard
today about different agents that are
being built how to build it what are the
Cool Tools out there to go build agents
and today we're going to actually talk
about when you put those agents into
production it's important to actually
know how they're doing and evaluate them
it's super important in making sure that
they actually work in the real world
we're probably going to get a little
technical in this talk maybe a little
bit more than some of the other talks
but hang in there I think this is
important even at the leadership level
to understand how to make sure what
you're putting out actually works in the
real world um so a little bit about me
my name is aparta I'm one of the
founders of arise uh fun update on us
actually today we announced our series C
race um
so um
have a lot of folks for are using us to
evaluate agents so with that let's jump
in okay well everyone here's probably
talked to you about text based agents so
you have this chat bot whatever it's
making an action and it's it's figuring
out all these things to do the cool next
Frontier is actually voice AI is already
taking over call centers there are over
1 billion calls made in call centers all
around the world with Voice Assistant a
with with voice apis and the the
realtime voice API if any of you guys
have played around with it we're
actually already seeing these types of
um agents start to take over and
revolutionize call centers this is
actually a real production application
of a travel agent this is the price line
pennybot you can go in and actually
handsfree no text book an entire
vacation using Price Line Penny today so
we're not just talking about tech based
agents anymore we're talking about
multimodal agents and it's important to
address these because the way that you
evaluate these types of Agents it's not
just evaluate an agent but also if it's
on voice there's specific types of
evaluations you're going to need to do
if it's multimodal there's additional
types of evaluations you need to
consider so we're going to break all
that down and hang in there with me for
a fun one today so before I jump in and
talk about how to evaluate an agent
let's talk about what are the components
of an agent you probably have heard
different versions of this today but but
I'll tell you the language we're going
to use one um there's something
typically called a
router uh which is essentially what's
deciding what the next step an agent
will take there's skills which is the
actual logical chains that do the work
and then there's something that stores
the memory this is important
because there might be different
architectures of how you're seeing
people build these agents out there
doesn't matter if you're using Lan graph
or crei or llama index workflow there's
all sorts of agent Frameworks they all
have slightly different ways of building
an agent you might not even use a
framework but what you're going to see
is these common patterns of okay that's
a router that's a skill and that's a
memory and these different components
are going to have different ways of how
you actually evaluate it so let's first
talk about the first one what the heck's
a router so you can think about a router
almost like the boss it's kind of
deciding hey well it's very common to
have e-commerce agents in you probably
are all talking to e-commerce agents
today to purchase things Amazon has one
all these e-commerce companies have one
when you type in a question like I want
to make a return give me an idea of what
to go buy are there any discounts on
this that user query funnels into
something called a router and that
router's goal is to is really to
determine do I call this skill about
hitting up a customer service agent do I
call this skill um to suggest all the
discounts we have or suggest product
products the router is really kind of
the boss deciding who do I tap on to go
actually execute the the ask that the
user made and the router might not
always get it right but you want it to
get it right because then it goes down
the pathway of a specific skill within
an agent so in this case it will call a
skill um so if I asked hey uh tell me
the best um I don't know leggings to go
byy so it'll go in it'll do a product
search and then this is actually the
entire skill flow of execution that the
agent needs to go through to execute you
know whatever the user asked for some of
these might be llm calls some of these
might just be API calls it just really
depends on how people actually Implement
them and then lastly this is an
important piece is there's always
something storing the memory because
these are usually not just single turn
conversations they're multi- turn
conversations multi-turn interactions
and so you don't want to be talking to
an agent that forgets what you
previously said so there's really memory
which is storing what it previously
asked for and keeping all this in some
sort of um in in some some sort of
semblance of state so with that we're
going to get a little fun here I'm going
to show you um an actual example of what
this could all look like a router skills
and memory so this is an open source
project um that actually looks at the
inner workings of an agent these are
called traces for folks who may not be
familiar if you're you know in
leadership or this is really what your
engineers are looking at when they're
actually building and troubleshooting
your agent they're actually
understanding what the heck went on
under the scenes so this is actually an
example of a code-based agent somebody
asked a question like what trends do you
see in my Trace latency AKA what's
making my application slow this is the
router call that we were talking about
earlier where it actually decides well
how do I then go ask how do I then go
tackle that question so first you can
see here there's multiple router calls
there's not just one router call this is
pretty common as your application grows
you can have multiple times where it
comes back and has to decide what do I
need to go do so the first time it calls
the router what it does is it actually
so the router then makes a tool call um
which is essentially this skill that you
need the first time it actually makes a
tool call to then go run a SQL query go
collect all of my traces of my
application and go go run a SQL query
then it goes back up to the router and
then it calls the second skill which is
actually the data analyzer skill which
takes all of the traces and the
application data and then it passes it
to something that actually analyzes that
data so in this case you can actually
see there was a router there was tool
calls we actually have memory that's
actually storing everything that's
happening under the scenes and so really
just shows all three of the different
components that I actually just walked
through so now that we have an example
of a of an agent with the router and
skills and memory let's talk about how
to actually evaluate these agents every
single step that I just walk through
here actually is an area where the agent
can go wrong for routers typically what
teams end up caring about is did it call
the right skill because if it didn't
call the right skill you know user asks
for I asked for leggings but then it
sent me over to customer service or it
sent me over to um you know uh something
about discounts and Deals so you
actually want to make sure that the
router within an agent is correctly
doing the right skill and calling the
right skill so that's the first piece
that you'll want to make sure that your
teams are evaluating so if your teams
are building agents you want to ask well
hey what's the ultimate control flow
what's the control flow and are do we
have something like a router and are we
evaluating it to make sure that it's
correctly calling the right skill
between ABC and is it calling the right
skill with the right parameters so not
just um a calling product search but
actually making sure that whatever way
you've designed that skill you're
actually passing in the correct things
like um you know I want this type of
material I want this type of whatever
cost range you're actually passing in
all the right parameters into what the
user actually is is asking for can I get
a raise of hands have any of you guys
heard of do any of you guys evaluate
your agents today actually is that
something you know your teams are doing
okay awesome are any of you guys
evaluating this router level internally
okay awesome wow this is a great group
okay
this is impressive um okay let's next go
to the next one which is actually
evaluating a skill this is actually the
part where it gets really interesting
and tricky because there's many
different components in a skill there
might be in this case I have a rag type
of skill so I want to look at things
like evaluating the actual relevance of
the chunks that were pulled I want to
look at the actual correctness of the
answer that was generated but this skill
itself can have many different
llm as a judge evals or it can also have
code-based evals that you might want to
run to actually evaluate the
skills the skills of the agent and then
lastly this is kind of a really
important one that we're seeing teams
probably have the most trouble
evaluating which is actually the path
that the agent took
because well ideally you want it to
converge you call the same skill
hundreds of times and it always takes
about five steps or six steps to
actually query what the user asked for
put in the right parameters call XYZ
components of the skill and then
ultimately um take the right you know
generate the right answer but sometimes
this can be a little longer we've seen
sometimes where the same skill and I
don't know if you all have done this
experiment but you can put the same
skill and build it with open the eye and
you can also build it with anthropic and
sometimes they have wildly different
number of steps that the path actually
takes and so the goal here is how do you
be succinct and how do you also make
sure there's reliability in the number
of steps that your agent takes to
actually consistently complete a task so
we call this convergence um but probably
one of the hardest to actually evaluate
is anyone evaluating convergence today
or at least counting the number of steps
awesome okay you're awesome
dude cool well with that I'm going to go
me maybe two more minutes then I'll hop
into one more demo here so if any of you
guys have watched the movie her this is
from
her um uh this is
where you know the the main character
asks like who else are you talking to
and you know the Samantha says something
like 8,000 other people are in a
conversation with me right now and so
the future of voice applications is that
these are probably some of the most
complex type of applications that have
ever been deployed ever been built it's
going to require one more additional
pieces to actually evaluate voice
applications and the interesting part
about these is that it's not just the
text that needs to be evaluated or the
transcript but it's also the audio chunk
that needs to be
evaluated um in a lot of these Voice
Assistant apis you have the generated
transcript that happens actually after
the audio chunk is really sent and so
that's a whole another dimension around
is the user how what's the user's
sentiment is the speech to text
transcription actually okay is the tone
consistent throughout the entire
conversation and so you actually need to
evaluate not just the audio piece and
the flow of the conversation and
everything else you're doing for all
your other you know other parts of your
agent but also make sure that the audio
chunks are getting their own evals
defined on um you know intent or speech
quality or speech detex accuracy
um so this is important for voice so
with that um I'm going to actually show
you guys how we evaluate our own agent
so that you can get a little bit of a
example of of what some agent in the
wild actually does um this is our own
agent so let me actually show you what
it looks like um you can actually go in
our product today and there's a little
co-pilot and our co-pilot does something
similar to what other co-pilots do do
where as people are spending time in our
product we actually help them do things
like hey help me debug this help me
summarize this help me look at this um
can I search with natural language
there's kind of this co-pilot integrated
throughout our entire product but we're
an eval company so what do we do we
actually dog food our own tool and we
decide to what you're looking at here is
actually the traces of our entire
co-pilot actually in the wild and every
single step of this co-pilot we actually
run evaluations of so in this case we
have an eval at the very top actually
evaluating something around was the
overall response that was generated this
was actually a search question is the
overall search question actually correct
or incorrect and then we also have one
around once it actually called the
search router did it pick the right
router and then did it pass in the
correct argument
into the router and then finally
ultimately did it complete the task or
the skill correctly in the execution of
this this entire skill and so evals
aren't just at one layer of your entire
Trace if you take anything away from
this conversation the goal here is
really how do you make sure that you
have evals throughout your application
so that when something goes wrong I can
debug if it actually happened at the
router level if it happened at the skill
level or if it happened happens
somewhere else along the flow um and I
think that's it from me any questions
[Music]
[Applause]